Yesterday, His Eminence Sheikh Dr. Zakir bin
Abdul Karim Nayiq, the Islamic Personality of the
17th session, was a guest of His Highness Sheikh
Mohammed bin Rashid Al Maktoum, Vice President, Prime Minister, and
Ruler of Dubai, may God protect him, the
patron and founder of the award. His Highness and his
guest discussed the Dubai International
Holy Quran Award and its service to those who memorize the Holy Quran.
This took place in the presence of His Highness Sheikh Maktoum bin Mohammed
bin Rashid Al Maktoum, Deputy Ruler of Dubai, and a number of
officials and members of the organizing committee of the
Dubai International Holy Quran Award.
His Highness then presented the
Islamic Personality of the Year award to His Eminence Sheikh Dr.
Zakir bin Abdul Karim
Nayiq.